nos dicen sea que una función derivarle
definida en el intervalo menos 44 la
gráfica de g se muestra a continuación y
tenemos esta gráfica que es mi gráfica
de x cuántos puntos de inflexión tiene
la gráfica g bueno primero vamos a
recordar que es un punto de inflexión
porque un punto de inflexión recuerda es
aquel punto en donde cambiamos de
concavidad es decir en donde vamos de
una concavidad hacia arriba y pasamos a
una concavidad hacia abajo
o viceversa o vamos desde una concavidad
hacia abajo
hasta una concavidad asia
bien esa es una forma de decirlo pero
tal vez otra forma de pensar en esto
mismo es decir son los puntos donde
pasamos de una pendiente creciente de
una pendiente que está creciendo déjame
tratarlo una pendiente
creciente
bueno una pendiente decreciente
a una pendiente que está decreciendo
esto para este primer caso o bueno
también lo podemos ver de la siguiente
manera como un punto donde pasamos de
una pendiente decreciente
a una pendiente creciente a una
pendiente que está creciendo
siguiente y eso me refiero para el otro
caso para este caso de aquí así que
pensemos un poco en esto
si te fijas aquí en esta gráfica que
tenemos am en este punto que tenemos más
a la izquierda puedes observar que
tenemos una pendiente muy grande tenemos
una pendiente muy muy grande y va a
seguir siendo una pendiente positiva
pero quiero que observes que poco a poco
está pendiente que es muy grande empieza
a decrecer se va volviendo cada vez
menos positiva y tal vez no lo parezca
pero se está aplanando un poco entonces
tenemos una pendiente muy grande por
aquí pero está decreciendo y se observa
se mantiene decreciendo se mantiene
decreciendo decreciendo decreciendo
hasta que llega un punto donde es cero y
después sigue decreciendo sigue
decreciendo sigue decreciendo sigue
creciendo y más o menos como por aquí
déjame
ponerlo con este color más o menos como
por aquí observa que empieza a crecer si
observas por aquí cambian y ahora por
kings empieza a crecer empieza a crecer
ya no decrece empieza a crecer empieza a
crecer hasta llegar como por aquí a este
punto de hecho donde x vale 0 parece que
la pendiente es 0 y ahora observa que
después de aquí parece que la pendiente
empieza a decrecer de nuevo así que
déjame ponerlo por acá empieza la
pendiente ha de crecer de nuevo
decrece de cree se decrece la pendiente
se vuelve cada vez más negativa y por
aquí parece que pasa de nuevo algo muy
interesante por aquí parece que otra vez
cambiamos desde crecer a crecer observa
que ahora muy pendiente va a empezar a
crecer al igual que aquí tenemos otro
punto interesante otro punto de
transición y ahora empieza
a crecer así que empieza a crecer
empieza a crecer se mantiene creciendo
cada vez es más positiva o menos
negativa porque observa es una pendiente
negativa pero cada vez es menos negativa
y después bueno aquí llega a ser cero y
sigue creciendo cree se cree se cree se
cree se crece crece y se mantiene
creciendo entonces un punto de inflexión
es un punto en donde cambiamos de una
pendiente creciente a una pendiente
decreciente como en este caso que
tenemos una pendiente creciente y la
cambiamos a una pendiente del creciente
este sería uno de nuestros puntos de
inflexión muy bien y el otro caso donde
cambiamos de una pendiente decreciente a
una pendiente creciente aquí tenemos una
pendiente decreciente y cambia a una
pendiente creciente así que esto también
es un punto de inflexión y bueno aquí
pasa lo mismo tenemos una pendiente
decreciente y cambia a una pendiente
crece
así que aquí también tenemos otro punto
de inflexión así que si queremos
responder cuántos puntos de inflexión
tiene la gráfica gm bueno podemos decir
que son 33 puntos de inflexión tiene la
gráfica g en el intervalo menos 4,4